[Musique]
n'ajustez pas votre appareil kent nagano
veut vous faire vivre une expérience
dans le noir
[Musique]
pourquoi pas essayer une fois de libre
et les oreilles et voir ce que ça donne
les musiciens ont suivi le chef dans ce
projet un peu fou y compris le
guitariste steve hill qui joue pour la
première fois avec un orchestre
symphonique
[Musique]
c'était ça son concept de ces quand
écoutent de la musique les yeux fermés
cela ressemble beaucoup plus tenté autre
sens par les ventes essence les chansons
sont plus sont décuplées le guitariste
admet que c'est tout un défi que de
créer ce concerto en première mondiale
[Musique]
dans ce programme où on retrouvera pas
ligety stackhouse zen et hendrix le
guitariste se sont quand même en pays de
connaissance
gentex fréquentes au dessus de la terre
c'est ma plus belle cinématique assez
années 60 la musique que je fais
extrêmement influencé par les années 60
pour qu'un tag anneaux ce programme
c'est une façon de créer des ponts entre
musique populaire et classique sera
aussi zarathoustra était encore grâce à
stanley kubrick réame 2001 spéciaux s'il
est devenu plutôt une partie de
pentecôte
pour l'occasion on a tendu à voile entre
les musiciens et le public qui diminuera
l'intensité de l'éclairage au dessus des
lutrins et tous les spectateurs auront
un masque pour vivre l'expérience sonore
dans le noir le plus complet possible
et maintenant place à la musique
et si l'animation radio canada montréal
[Musique]